und jetzt haben wir Robert lampruh bei
uns sind Spitzenkandidat der AFD in
Hessen für die Landtagswahl am 8 Oktober
sind sie eigentlich neidisch auf die
Spitzenkandidaten der AFD in Sachsen
Thüringen für nächstes Jahr denn wir
könnten ja den Einzug in die
Staatskanzlei schaffen das würde man in
Hessen wahrscheinlich kaum erwarten aber
Herr Killer vielen Dank für die
Einladung ich freue mich dass ich
Spitzenkandidat in Hessen bin das ist
meine Wahlheimat ich bin seit 2008 in
Hessen erst in Frankfurt und jetzt seit
zehn Jahren schon in Wiesbaden also ich
fühle mich pudelwohl für die AFD in
Hessen der Spitzenkandidat zu sein
anders als in Thüringen wird es aber
wahrscheinlich keine Möglichkeit geben
die bisherige Koalition aus Schwarz-Grün
oder Jamaika sozusagen zu verhindern da
sind sie weit davon entfernt jetzt ist
ja die Frage gerade in den westlichen
Bundesländern auch wenn ihre Umfrage
Ergebnisse gerade ziemlich gut sind wie
wollen sie sich da profilieren da haben
sie doch noch Luft nach oben wenn Sie
sich mit den ostdeutschen
Landesverbänden vergleichen also die
Umfragewerte in Ostdeutschland und in
Westdeutschland die sind hauptsächlich
deswegen unterschiedlich weil in
Ostdeutschland halt viele Menschen noch
die DDR erlebt haben und die haben viel
feinere Antenne für Entwicklungen die
ins Negative gehen wir sehen aber auch
jetzt bei den bundesweiten Umfragen wo
die AFD mittlerweile stabil egal welches
meinungsinstitut bei 20% oder mehr steht
dass ich gerade in Westdeutschland
gewaltig etwas bewegt und wie weit das
noch trägt das ist gar nicht abzusehen
sagen die feineren Antennen der Menschen
in Ostdeutschland wegen ihrer DDR
Sozialisation das heißt die im Westen
haben gar nicht nur noch nicht so
richtig begriffen was eigentlich gut für
sie ist gerade was die Politik der AFD
angeht also meine Wahrnehmung ist dass
es sich gerade in Westdeutschland für
die Partei dreht wir haben eine
unglaubliche Mitglieder Eintrittswelle
und der Schwerpunkt dieser
Eintrittswelle der liegt auf den
westdeutschen Landesverbänden deswegen
ist es schwer zu sagen wie sich die
Wahlergebnisse am 8 Oktober darstellen
werden bisher hat halt gegolten dass die
Ostdeutschen da wesentlich kritischer
waren wesentlich feinen Antennen hatten
aber ich glaube dass viele westdeutsche
Bürger aufgewacht sind die Energiepreise
sind mit die höchsten in Europa und der
Welt und eine Mehrheit der Menschen ist
für den Weiterbetrieb von
Kernkraftwerken die AFD ist fast die
einzige Partei die diese politische
Position vertritt
wenn man von dem bundesweiten
Wahlergebnissen ausgeht das hätte die
hessische um die hessischen Umfragen
sind nicht weit weg davon ich meine ich
bundesweite Wahlergebnisse sondern
Umfragen so um die 20 knapp unter 20%
heißt ja das auch 80% eben nicht AFD
wählen wollen
die Wahrnehmung der AFD gerade im Westen
ist noch nicht so stark wie im Osten da
gehört sie ja sozusagen zu den ganzen
gesellschaftlichen Abläufen im Westen
doch nicht so sehr liegt das vielleicht
auch daran dass für manche weiß ist die
Ostdeutschen Landesverbände zu radikal
sind oder zu radikal daherkommen also
ich sehe in Ostdeutschland dass die 40
Jahre
unterschiedlicher Sozialisation einfach
auch ein bisschen unterschiedliche
Mentalitäten hervorgebracht haben und
wenn sie bei den anderen Parteien gucken
sind die Ostdeutschen Landesverbände
dort auch ein bisschen kerniger das ist
keine Spezialität der Alternative für
Deutschland
jetzt scheint ja bei der AFD auch etwas
Partylaune zu herrschen nicht nur weil
heute Abend noch zehn Jahre AFD gefeiert
wird sondern auch wegen der guten
Umfrageergebnisse auch wegen der Fehler
die die Konkurrenz im Umgang mit der AFD
macht diese Gefahr dass die Partei
möglicherweise da etwas zu euphorisch
wird auch zu selbstgefällig zu sie
gesichert und das böse Erwachen kommen
dann am Wahlabend also Wahlumfragen sind
keine Wahlergebnisse das ist etwas was
die Grünen ja immer wieder erleben die
da sehr überschätzt werden und dann
Wahlabend viel geringer abschneiden
ich bespreche mit meinen Kollegen schon
seit längerem dass
Wahlumfragen in dieser Höhe wie wir sie
in Hessen haben erst einmal eine enorme
Verpflichtung sind da sind viele
Menschen die setzen ihre Hoffnungen in
uns die haben sehr stark das Gefühl dass
es gegen sie geht das immer weniger Geld
im Geldbeutel bei ihnen übrig bleibt
dass sie oft nicht mehr wissen
Monatsende wie sie sich das Geld
einteilen sollen die Energiekosten sind
hoch sie sehen bei der Ampel das wenig
Rücksicht genommen wird und sagen dann
wähle ich jetzt mal die Alternative für
Deutschland und dieser Verantwortung und
das ist ganz ganz wichtig wir müssen wir
uns dann auch als gerecht erweisen Boris
rein der Spitzen kann ja der Union und
amtierende Ministerpräsident der hat ja
gesagt die brandbauer zu AFD steht der
meinte natürlich den ersten die
Landespolitik sollte jetzt zum Beispiel
was ja nicht unwahrscheinlich ist
Schwarz-Grün keine Mehrheit mehr haben
nach der Wahl werden Sie Boris rein
trotz dieser Absage und dem Stühlen vor
die Tür stellen und Gespräche anbieten
also erst einmal gilt es war in
Deutschland noch nie eine gute Idee
Mauern zu errichten
Boris rein hat von uns einige Themen
übernommen er möchte die
Grunderwerbsteuer in Hessen
reduzieren er ist für den Weiterbetrieb
oder die Wiedereinstieg in die Kernkraft
grundsätzlich in vielen Punkten in einer
Richtung wo ich ganz klar sage das kann
er inhaltlich am besten mit der AFD in
Hessen Umsetzen in einer Neuauflage der
schwarz-grünen Koalition eher nicht und
insofern ist es eine Frage ob er sich
von solchen ideologischen
Überlegungen löst und dann ist die
Alternative für Deutschland eigentlich
thematisch am dichtesten bei seinen
politischen Vorstellungen dran aber er
hat die Brandmauer gerade erneut
bekräftigt ja wenn Boris rein genau
schaut dann gibt es auch in Hessen
bereits auf kommunaler Ebene die ein
oder andere Zusammenarbeit zwischen der
CDU und der AFD
möglicherweise auch noch mit anderen
Parteien die man das so hört bei uns war
Robert Land bruh der Spitzenkandidat der
AFD in Hessen für die Landtagswahl im
Oktober danke dass sie da waren